since the early morning hours and
throughout last night
the lebanese army and fire
fighters have been still trying to put
off the fire which is still until today
burning through the remains of the
warehouses at the port of the city of
beirut the
lebanese president michelle own has
announced two
weeks emergency state of emergency in
beirut
today we're expecting an emergency
session to be held at the lebanese
cabinet we're expecting a lot of
decisions and sacking of
port officials who are accused of
negligence
that had a lot to do whose shortcomings
had a lot to do with why
this entire situation took the turn it
did yesterday rescue workers are still
trying to dig through the rubble
to find the remainder or the the missing
individuals as well as
if they can find more bodies
unfortunately we are expecting that the
death toll is going to continue to rise
because of how massive the blast was and
because
the staff of the port were at the at the
port
and the time of the blas or in the time
of the explosion
you